so tooth fairy is an interesting dilemma
when you're a parent because right when
they're losing teeth they're supremely
gullible they'll believe basically
anything you tell them because they
don't have a their own sense of the
world yet their understanding filters
through what you deliver to them as a
parent as a trusting parent so the two
of us we're sitting there say what do we
do about their loss two teeth so here's
what we did they lose your tooth and say
mommy daddy what should I do with our
two here's what we did we said we heard
that if you put it under your pillow a
tooth fairy comes and swaps it out with
money we heard this we're not sure that
okay said okay then they did that so
they put it over envelope it under the
pillow next morning there's money there
so look mommy daddy the Tooth Fairy came
and so I asked them how do you know they
said oh well there's money there I said
okay but how do you know it was a tooth
fairy
and so they're my kids for every next
tooth would rig apparatus in their room
to detect things that might come in
their room overnight like put aluminum
foil on the grounds because you could
hear that crinkle if somebody walks in
and they started rigging all of this
then at school they organized a tooth
fairy experiment it was someone had the
idea that maybe as the parents who are
the Tooth Fairy okay so how do you test
that here's how you test it anybody
whose tooth came out in school you do
not tell your parents about it you then
put that tooth under your pillow and see
what happens and so the next kids whose
tooth came out of it they did this and
the next morning it was still a tooth
and so they busted the tooth fairy
legend
so they got to turn a a tooth fairy
fantasy into a scientific experiment I
don't have a problem with and at no time
did I say there's no tooth fairy they
figured it out
that's how we deal with the tooth fairy
in my household